i didn't send a dick pic to my mom
oh you know when you said the text
you're like no no no no no no no
now i will tell you at first i was
really upset
but then i started to think if i was
gonna send an accidental dick
here it is look it's not just because i
like weird [ __ ] which i do
there's not a whole lot weirder than
sending a dick pic to your mom
and it's not just because i think funny
wins in [ __ ] feelings because i do
and there's not a lot funnier than
sending a dick pic if you want
but the real reason i was glad i sent it
to my mom
is because
she's such a supportive person
you know
i thought the worst i was going to get
back is my texts like that looks great
honey or something like that
and she ghosted me
no text for like four hours you know i
always send their texts like are we
gonna talk about my dick or what
and then about the four hour mark i just
got this text from her
it was the worst decks i could have
gotten i didn't know at the time it was
the worst text but hindsight this is the
worst text she could have said she just
sent texts back and said
what is that
and i was like i almost texted my dad
like send me a picture of your dick
right now let's see
are ours that different are you packing
a hammer like what the [ __ ] is going
[Music]
but you know how the story goes another
day another dollar howler 7 p.m once
again i'm breaking up the birds